en esta ocasión vamos a hablar de un
circuito muy importante en la
electrónica y es el circuito resistencia
capacitor o circuito rc y en este vídeo
vamos a hablar en particular sobre la
respuesta natural de un circuito rc la
respuesta natural es lo que ocurre
cuando ponemos de inicio un poco de
energía en el circuito y en el caso de
un circuito rc va a representar la carga
almacenada en el capacitor al inicio del
análisis vamos a hacer una descripción
intuitiva de lo que sucede en el
circuito cuando este interruptor cambia
de esta posición a esta otra posición
cuando este interruptor pasa de esta
posición en donde está conectando la
batería a la combinación rc y después lo
vamos a mover y pondremos ahora el
interruptor aquí veremos qué ocurre
conforme el capacitor se descarga de
vuelta a través de la resistencia y ese
patrón de descarga es a lo que le
llamamos la respuesta natural veamos el
circuito como está actualmente diga
que el interruptor ha estado en esta
posición durante bastante tiempo y en
algún momento en el pasado hubo cierta
corriente que estaba fluyendo por acá
esa corriente pasó a través de la
resistencia y llegó a este capacitor y
esto nos dejó con cierta carga aquí
ahora hagamos un acercamiento al
capacitor conforme la carga fluye aquí
se va a acumular en este lado del
capacitor y tenemos la correspondiente
carga negativa en este otro lado del
capacitor esta cantidad de carga
coincide con la cantidad de carga que
tenemos aquí y es a esto a lo que nos
referimos con que la carga q se está
acumulando en el capacitor y para la
estructura del capacitor sabemos que la
carga aquí es igual al valor de la
capacitancia multiplicada por el voltaje
así que conforme más carga se acumula
aquí el voltaje aumenta se es un valor
fijo no cambia es una propiedad del
capacitor si la carga aumenta entonces
el voltaje también aumenta
regresamos aquí y veamos qué ocurre
conforme esta corriente llega al
capacitor se acumula la carga y
eventualmente el voltaje de aquí va a
aumentar hasta que sea igual a más menos
de cero y en este punto cuando el
voltaje es igual a de cero el voltaje a
través de la resistencia se va a detener
así que la corriente aquí va a ser igual
a cero y el voltaje en este punto va a
ser de cero vamos a graficar esto vamos
a dibujar como luce esta respuesta estos
son nuestros ejes del tiempo esto es
vedete que es este voltaje de aquí
vt y aquí tendremos el dt y vamos a
decir que esta y dt es esta corriente de
acá y en un momento verán porque puse la
dirección de esta corriente con este
sentido particular así pues al inicio
antes de cambiar el interruptor que
vamos a mover hacia acá pero antes de
que lo hagamos
tenemos de 0 en el capacitor y tenemos y
de t
0 vamos a graficar estos valores aquí
antes de que el tiempo sea 0 tenemos de
0 aquí y esta corriente de aquí es 0
ahora sí ya estamos listos para cambiar
el interruptor borramos esto y dibujamos
esto ahora nuestro interruptor está en
esta posición y ahora que la batería ya
hizo su trabajo la vamos a quitar de
aquí ya no la necesitamos porque ya
cargó por completo al capacitor aquí
está nuestro circuito simplificado y
tenemos bastante carga almacenada en el
capacitor ahora qué va a pasar pues esta
carga va a comenzar a salir del
capacitor va a pasar por la resistencia
se va por todo este camino para
básicamente neutralizar la carga del
otro lado del capacitor si lo vemos acá
vamos a ver que la carga va a salir por
aquí arriba va a pasar por la
resistencia va a regresar por este otro
lado
cargas negativas se van a neutralizar
con las cargas positivas que están
llegando por acá lo que significa que si
no tenemos una carga neta el voltaje va
a ser igual a cero vamos a graficar lo
después de que toda esta carga sale por
acá pasa por la resistencia y llega a
este otro lado terminando del otro lado
del capacitor neutralizando la carga del
circuito significa que el voltaje en el
circuito va a ser igual a cero vamos a
dibujarlo después de cierto tiempo
más adelante nuestra gráfica se va a ver
así no tendremos voltaje y de igual
forma no tendremos corriente una vez que
todo esto ya se haya descargado y es lo
que ocurre con todas las respuestas
naturales básicamente toda la energía en
el circuito va a llegar a cero ahora
veamos si descubrimos qué es lo que
sucede en el intervalo este voltaje
comenzó en vez cero y va a terminar en
cero la cantidad de corriente que va a
fluir por acá va a ser proporcional al
voltaje que pasa a través de ésta
asistencia así que la cantidad de
corriente que fluye es igual a 1 / r por
b por lo que si b es grande entonces y
también va a ser grande y conforme va
haciéndose más pequeño b conforme usamos
nuestra carga la corriente también va a
disminuir así que podemos adivinar qué
es lo que va a suceder aquí va a ir
disminuyendo hasta que termine en 0
después de cierto tiempo aún no sabemos
cuánto tiempo le llevará a esto pero
sabemos que la forma va a ser así y
ahora qué va a pasar con la corriente
antes de mover el interruptor la
corriente es igual a 0 en el momento en
el que movemos el interruptor y lo
conectamos aquí de pronto tendremos b 0
de este lado de la resistencia y 0 de
este lado de la resistencia por lo que
de pronto tendremos un incremento
importante de corriente en la
resistencia así que aquí vemos un brinco
hasta cierto valor como va a lucir la
corriente no tenemos por acá es
directamente proporcional al voltaje así
que conforme baja el voltaje
también va a bajar y podemos imaginar
que va a tener una forma bastante
parecida a la del voltaje va a verse más
o menos así hasta que llegue a cero y
esta es nuestra predicción de cómo luce
la respuesta natural de un circuito rc
en el siguiente vídeo vamos a deducir
expresiones precisas de cómo lucen estas
curvas